[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
la reprise de sa vodka dit aujourd'hui
avec notre invité le président de la
fcpe martinique claude bertrac bonjour
bonjour voilà alors la fcpe c'est la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves et vous êtes président de
l'antenne régionale donc de martinique
de cette fcpe donc fédération de niveau
national alors clos bertrac c'est jour
de rentrée scolaire
après les vacances de pâques et oui oui
et un mojo voilà mais pas pour tous les
élèves en ce lundi 12 avril nous y
reviendrons
mais pour les écoles maternelles
élémentaires selon le communiqué de
presse de l'académie de martinique la
rentrée s'effectue aujourd'hui
normalement
ben c'est le terme qui l'utilisé en
classe complète dans le respect des
règles sanitaires déjà en vigueur
apparemment ça vous satisfait qu'ils
aient cette rentrée pour le primaire
alors aujourd'hui d'une manière générale
il faut comprendre que l'enjeu il faut
il faut reposer la problématique parce
que tout le monde parle d'une certaine
manière mais sans vraiment posé la
problématique la commune indique c'est
quoi c'est la réussite éducative de nos
enfants à partir de là on va décliner
comment faire réussir nos enfants et ça
c'est fondamental et je dirais même
c'est un acte politique pour le pays
parce que faire réussir nos enfants
pourquoi est ce de manière individuelle
ou de manière collective nous
l'accepterons s'inscrit dans une
politique nationale quand je dis
nationale pour le pays martinique c'est
à dire je suis pas en train de faire de
la politique politicienne mais pour bien
comprendre l'enjeu
chaque petit martiniquais d'où ils
viennent quelle que soit sa religion sa
couleur son origine doit réussir ici
dans cette optique que nous nous
inscrivons et c'est pour cela que nous
disons que l'éducation comme l'a dit
quelqu'un avant moi monsieur joseph
zobel qui dit que la deuxième clé qui va
nous ouvrir la porte de la liberté c'est
l'éducation
donc il est important de tout faire ou
permettre aux enfants de riom maintenant
nous avons une pandémie
on va pas dire que c'est quelque chose à
la légère
il faut en prendre comment dirais-je
tout le poids de cette pandémie et les
conséquences il ya même mort d'homme
nous sommes d'accord mais faudrait-il
tous fermés c'est ça qu'on pose comme
question
et n'oubliez pas le pendant qu'il faut
la réussite éducative de nos enfants il
faut s'adapter premier confinement on a
confiné tout le monde
on était d'accord maintenant il faut s'y
habituer alors mais justement là par
exemple pour les élèves des écoles
maternelles et élémentaires à votre
connaissance en tant que président de la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves comment ça se passe pour
aujourd'hui ce 12 avril
alors qu'on sort des vacances de pâques
qui a eu un couvre feu renforcé pour
ainsi dire juste à l'orée des vacances
et puis là comment ça se passe quand on
dit que la rentrée s'effectue
normalement entre guillemets c'est pas
dans les conditions habituelles
c'est normal comment ça se fait en
présentiel en distance yale comme on
laissera tout ça
d'abord pour le primaire d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un lien de la primaire
normalement c'est normalement jusqu'à
présent les écoles sont ouvertes
normalement
voilà normalement à la cantine avec des
enseignants peut être exaucé vacciner en
plus grand nombre d'ailleurs parce qu'on
a vu qu'on a beaucoup qui ont profité de
ces vacances wheeler pour prendre leur
vaccin c'est à dire comme je vous dis
tout et permettent aux enfants de
réussir donc qu'il veut ce vaccin qui
porte le masque et nous nous sommes
d'accord avec ça c'est à dire que à bon
voilà c'est ça parce que c'est important
par exemple la vaccination
qu'on soit pour ou contre 1 ça c'est
autre chose mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que plus il y aura d'enseignants
vacciner rapidement sur le principe a
priori moins y en aura qui ce qui risque
d'être absent par la suite
en tout cas en raison de gérer le d'être
atteint par les jeunes avaient apporté
aux enseignants qui ne sont pas vaccinés
le poids d'une culpabilité
donc je vais pas entrer sur ce terrain
soit cas jeudi c'est à dire qu'il est
important que nos enfants retrouvent les
bancs de l'école nous arrive c'est que
nous prenons acte que la pandémie c'est
quelque chose qui crée une certaine peur
même au niveau des parents d'élèves
mais jeudi il important que nos enfants
réussissent donc prenons les conditions
maintenant on a du recul
d'accord par exemple nous au niveau de
l'ebe ses pleurs on a toujours dit qu'il
faut alléger les effectifs même en école
primaire
nous regrettons après consultation avec
le nombre d'élèves tout à
paradoxalement nous regrettons que l'on
effectué roi ait préféré maintenir
l'ensemble des enfants pour le primaire
la totalité des effectifs
nous le regrettons mais nous disons est
ce qu on s'ennuie ou de fermer parce que
la fermeture sèche des établissements
scolaires c'est pas une solution
nous on peut s'amuser mais en difficulté
aussi un certain nombre de parents
d'élèves un une fois que les enfants
sont reviennent à la maison sont pas à
l'école mais localement en bas âge tout
ça n'est ce pas la difficulté des
parents qui m'importe c'est le fait que
semblant difficultés de l'enfant et son
avenir
c'est pour ça je reste sur ce point
central quel enfant parce qu'un enfant à
la maison il faut pas se faire
d'illusions le distanti elle ne
fonctionne pas surtout pour le primeur
ça ne fonctionne pas et les enseigner je
vais vous dire les enseignants qui ont
fait du dih essentielle préféré en
présentiel
parce que ça démontre deux fois plus de
travail des enseignants alors il y a
également donc la rentrée je le disais
un petit peu et aller alors en revanche
c'est aujourd'hui aussi pour les
personnels du secondaire pour qu'il
prépare la rentrée des élèves mais
refroidi mercredi tout à quel est votre
avis là-dessus mais nous sommes nous
sommes nous sommes une sont d'accord
avec ce procédé parce que quand le
secondaire collèges lycées se fait en
demies jauge c'est à dire à moitié des
effectifs ce qu'on a toujours demandé
depuis la rentrée
d'accord il faut bien préparer ce ces
2011 c'est à dire on va pas faire
soigner tous les enfants jouent guère
dire une partie pouvait pas rater
aujourd'hui et voix valides sommes donc
c'est une décision très sage capri le
rectorat que de que de faire venir les
enseignants pendant 48 heures pour
préparer cette contrée est alors du coup
il y abondent les collèges
effectivement mais surtout au niveau des
lycées il y a maintenant qu'on est à la
mi avril
la question de la préparation du
baccalauréat 2021
comme l'an dernier puisque ça fait plus
d'un an de pandémie maintenant comme
l'an dernier tout ça ça va être un petit
peu troublé voire même perturbé
comment alors oui il ya une partie des
épreuves qui ont été annulés 1
pour revenir à l'actualité transformer
un contrôle continu
c'est ça les épreuves de spécialistes
étrangers avoir dit que le mois dernier
tout a feinté supprimer c'est devenu
contre continental au long de la ligne
en soi même on est un peu perdu dans
cette affaire de préparation du
baccalauréat vandal a répondu oui oui
oui mais là pour cette ânerie d'accord
allemand les choses en face nous avons
posé la question et le rectorat leur
coeur nous a dit que rien n'a changé
c'est à dire que les enfants et c'est
pour cela que nous fédération de parents
d'élèves fcpe
nous militons pour le présentiel parce
qu'il faut que nos enfants soient
préparés c'est à dire quand vous ne
pouvez pas aller si on ne va pas aller
faire son match retour sans préparer son
match d'accord donc on proposa donc les
enfants ne peuvent pas si nous voulons
être sérieux et que les enfants puissent
réussir il faut qu'il soit en présentiel
c'est-à-dire qu'ils aient la présence
d'adultes et des enseignants formés que
nous avons avec les retours que vous
avez du terrain de la part de deux de
vos mandants quoi au sein de la
fédération des conseils des parents
d'élèves
est ce que il y a des des élèves des
lycéens notamment et leurs parents aussi
qui ont du mal à garder leur motivation
là pour cette prochaine échéance qui
arrive parce que c'est le bac c'est noir
un mois et demi deux mois
mais même pas notre question elle est
pertinente dans le sens que je comme je
vous dis c'est pour cela que nous
militons pour le présentiel parce que on
ne sait plus certains parents ne savent
plus à quel saint se vouer
parce que y'a pas il ya une certitude
pour l'avenir et c'est pour cela que le
fait que les enfants
les diodes qui met ce que nous avons pu
faire et nous remercions l'ensemble des
enseignants des parents d'élèves et des
ddv des fonctionnaires non enseignants
du personnel non enseignant merci ait pu
faire que ces deux trimestre et eu lieu
même s'il a prédit metella aujourd'hui
le retour que nous avons des parents ils
sont satisfaits et le retour comme ça me
désole scolaire n'a pas été trop troglos
d'angoulême en cette année scolaire 2005
1021 tout en maintenant un rapport à
2020 ils sont très satisfaits d'être
d'avant étaient présents et que les
enseignants ont joué le jeu et est
aujourd'hui on voit que les enfants sont
mieux préparés que l'année dernière
alors je voulais avoir votre avis sur le
fait que l'académie a lancé un appel
elle recherche des agents contractuels
pour des remplacements notamment
justement dans le secondaire vous êtes
aux commandes saas et voilà c'est ça la
de février dernier
voilà le rectorat de martinique
recherche urgemment des agents
contractuels pour enseigner dans les
établissements du second degré alors il
ya une série de disciplines on pourra
pas tout mais l'espagnol documentation
lettres modernes histoire géographie
sciences et techniques médico social
enfin sciences économiques et sociales
génie construction etc
alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est dommage
parce que c'est ça fait des années que
nous disons que pour enseigner pour
permettre aux enfants de réussir il faut
des enseignants et on ne veut pas
prendre des enseignants parce que c'est
de lui même c'est pas juste un outil que
vous faites que vous fabriquez c'est des
enfants que vous enseignez ça et à toute
une technique et à toute une commande il
a une maîtrise de la chose à avoir et
aujourd'hui prend des recherches et des
gens de manière précipitée
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas préparé la
venue et c'est la conséquence d'une
politique menée depuis des années du
démantèlement de l'éducation nationale
avec le dr traquons roues pour conclure
avec vous aujourd'hui vous êtes le
président de la fcpe de martinique
on rappelle qu évidemment tout ça crée
un contexte psychologique et ça fait
plus d'un an maintenant pour des parents
d'élèves qui quittent donc depuis un an
s'ils ont leurs enfants scolarisés c'est
pas toujours évident vous avez animé des
ateliers en début d'année atelier 2021
l'atelier du lien que vous faites mais
avec des thèmes évidemment lié avec
toute la pandémie
notamment comment dirais-je par rapport
à l'état psychologique parce que ça
touche toutes les familles donc les
élèves les parents les cool mes parents
à l'écouté des enfants et nous avons
constaté qu'en 2020 qu il y avait un
problème psychologique c'est un cycle
part au niveau du confinement savait
créer beaucoup de troubles
psychologiques chez les enfants et nous
avons voulu accompagner les parents pour
pouvoir mieux prendre en compte l'âge
cette problématique celle de chercher un
thème précis vous aviez parmi des
ateliers le thème c'est l estime de soi
abso les parents et les enfants et les
enfants ont conclu quelques mots
là-dessus oui oui donc nous avons voulu
nous avons toujours accompagner les
parents parce que l'enfant comme je vous
dis et ça rejoint mon mot de départ
c'est la réussite éducative pour pouvoir
réussir il faut avoir une bonne estime
de soi
donc nous équipons nous donnons des
outils aux enfants aux familles pour
pouvoir permettre alors en voie de
réussir
merci pour avoir fait le point
claude bertrac président de la fcpe de
martinique sur donc quasiment cette fin
d'année scolaire puisque on entame le
dernier trimestre voilà la dernière
ligne droite
l'imi boncourt à abancourt âge à toutes
et à tous un mot vous disiez que vous
n'êtes pas opposer enfin voulait pas
qu'on nous oppose les syndicats
d'enseignants et des parents d'élèves
en deux phrases là dessus absolument il
nous indique à ce syndicat km beaucoup
de réserves quand même sur les
conditions d'un compagnon parce que
quand vous posez toutes mes
interventions depuis le début d'année
nous demandons que les choses les
mesures soient appliquées les bonnes
mesures sont appliquées par rapport à
cette mode ému qu'il faut pas mettre en
danger ni l'avis des enseignants et la
vie des élèves venir à vis du personnel
non enseignant
parce que je rappelle rapidement que les
gens veulent frapper sur l'école fermer
l'école fermé d'écoles famille l'école
mais c'est pas les élèves qui ont couru
le carnaval pendant les vacances de
pâques à la plage voix est tout le monde
donc et l'école j'ai dit c'est le centre
est sûre quand nous disons à la fcpe
c'est que l'enseignement et à l'esprit
ce que l'aliment et pour le co donc il
est important de trouver les bonnes
méthodes pour que les enfants plus cette
voiture voir cet enseignement pour
pouvoir réussir
merci voilà vous retrouver jimmy damas
bonne journée et bonne semaine